hey guys it's Justine and today's
unboxing is gonna be so much fun I have
a bunch of gear from Colombia a huge
thank you to Columbia for partnering
with me on this video today I'm going to
be showcasing their Columbia Omni heat
Infinity technology now this is featured
in a ton of their jackets boots
outerwear so I'm so excited to get my
hands on it and check it out now not
only are we going to be doing an
unboxing but to show how this technology
actually works to keep you warm my
sister and I are going to be heading
into a cryo chamber I will be wearing
some of the Columbia omniheat Infinity
technology clothing and she will not so
clearly I'm gonna have a very unfair
Advantage so hopefully I'll be able to
withstand the cold and she will not this
is of course a competition so let's see
who wins oh I'm going in there
but first i'm going to unblock some of
this gear and check it out I'm actually
so excited about this because my family
has been a huge Columbia fan forever
like when I told my mom that I was doing
this video she got so hyped because she
has so many Columbia jackets I actually
every time I go home I always wear one
of hers that has the omniheat infinity
technology so I already know how
incredible it is so I'm so excited to
check this out for their new fall lineup
let's go we have so many goodies I can't
wait to check it out
the first item we're going to be opening
up is this this is the women's Payton
pass insulated jacket look at this
beautiful color oh I love this so me and
my sister are from the East Coast so
when we go home for the holidays or even
in the fall or even the beginning of the
year it is freezing so I'm very excited
to really get prepped with this cryo
chamber challenge to get us ready for
this winter this is where you're really
going to see the Omni heat Infinity
technology
all of these gold little dots not only
is it beautiful but it's actually
functional this lining is actually
thousands of little gold dots that
reflect and retain the body heat this
will provide you instant warmth without
sacrificing breathability Omni heat
Infinity is the gold standard in warmth
and in 2022 Columbia is continuing to
grow the product line to offer even more
options for warmth
oh my gosh it's so comfortable and this
hat is comfy oh my goodness cryo chamber
I'm so ready for you
I don't want to take it off let's see
what else we have to go with this let's
take a little look at these shoes
[Music]
I love hiking at any temperature I don't
care what it is so I'm excited to try
these out during my winter hikes oh
perfect fit too
These are nice look look at that bottom
I love having some extra tread here I
love all three gear so long with the
jacket I got a matching pair of gloves
these are also touch screen compatible
which is very important not gonna lie
ready for the winter times look at that
we're scrolling we're scrolling the
gloves have not only passed the fit
check they've also passed the scroll
check we've also got a hat check this
out it's crazy to think but pretty soon
there's gonna be snow on the ground and
I'm gonna actually need all of these
items this is another Omni Heat shirt
I like that they not only have this Omni
heat technology in their jackets but
they also have it in various pieces of
clothing as well I'm going to be so
prepped for this challenge Jenna isn't
even gonna know actually she'd kind of
knows the challenge is going to be
unfair because she has a few jackets
with the Omni heat Infinity technology
and she's already said that's not fair
because I already know how warm it is
it's got some pants as well oh wow these
are
these feel so comfy this has the Omni
Shield this has advanced water repellent
I like these have some little additional
secret Pockets to hide all my snacks
when I'm out this one when I saw on the
website
I was like this is what I need for cozy
season I love flannel so much that I had
a problem for a while like my sister was
like you have to stop buying it like I
feel like I want to go pick some
pumpkins now and we also have another
this is the same as the black one but I
like this color because this will match
the jacket that I got as well I could
probably live in the cryo chamber at
this point with all of this gear I'm
gonna be so warm so now that I have all
of my gear unboxed I need to go prep and
get ready for the cryo chamber I hope
Jenna's ready because I know I am the
time is now so we are heading into a
cryo chamber I have never done this
before have you no absolutely not
because I hate being cold I absolutely
hate being cold I'm the worst I mean if
it gets below like 70 I am full blankets
I've got jackets on don't like to be
cold so what's actually going to happen
this is a challenge right so yes so
we're each gonna go into the cryo
chamber at separate times now we're not
going to know each other's times until
the end so we don't know who actually
won the challenge so the goal is to stay
in the longest and of course this is
going to be kind of cheating a little
bit because we are going to be wearing
some outdoor gear but these can get up
to not up to down to like a negative 120
Fahrenheit she actually said it could go
as low as negative like 200 Fahrenheit
on a good day I said a good day that
sounds like a bad day to me but do you
think today is going to be a good or bad
day here's where you have the advantage
yeah because I have the Columbia Omni
heat technology in my clothes so I'm
basically I'm cheating to be completely
honest with you yeah so I'm going to
really do my best here because I don't
have that but uh good luck to you the
thing is you actually do have some
Columbia gear but you're not allowed to
wear it not allowed to wear it I had to
leave it at home I had to wear a
competitor brand sorry not sorry so I
definitely feel like I already have an
advantage but let's try this out ready
no yes sure
in we go face the freeze
[Music]
oh my goodness okay right now it's
pre-cooling so we're each gonna go in
one by one we have a timer here and then
whoever can stay in the longest wins the
challenge that's I'm already cold I know
my butt's cold this is very intimidating
oh I guess oh it's ready it's ready oh
my gosh okay I'm gonna go first okay and
then I'm not gonna tell you my my score
good luck
[Music]
so I'm a little nervous but I'm also not
that nervous because even before when I
was in my house and trying this on I was
sweating so I'm fully prepared and
confident that I'm might get a little
chilly but I'll be able to withstand all
of the temperatures
[Music]
I'm going in there
oh boy
okay Jenna's gonna do the honors and hit
start I'm going in guys I'm going in
okay I'm in I'm in go for it
okay
yeah you can't know how long I'm in here
so far I feel nothing yet my body feels
perfectly fine but the only thing that I
feel a slight chill
is on my hands
but it's not they're not even that cold
this is like a walk in the park
thank you
legs body
feels perfectly fine I know what Jenna's
wearing and she's gonna be freaking
freezing like I could probably be in
here for an hour and be fine
the only thing is like my hands are a
little cold a little cold on the pinkies
[Music]
negative 112.
at what temperature do zippers get
Frozen
look at that look at that look at that
look at that okay my hands are cold this
is the only thing that's cold feet feel
fine oh yeah we're fine
I'm seeing little bits of ice crystals
forming on my my hands I do think if
this was like a full body with my face
in there
I don't know how I'd feel
I'm glad that my face is out hands are a
little cold
let's keep it going let's keep it going
come on we got this
I also forgot to take my rings off which
was a very very poor move on my part
what a dumb move that was
this is going to be really unfair to
Jenna so I think the next time that it
times out I'm just gonna be like all
right I'm done eight minutes
[Music]
all right I'm tapping out only because I
know for a fact gemma's not gonna be
able to withstand this so there's no
reason to even keep going um how do I
get out of here
oh
my goodness wait look I have ice all
over me
so I definitely should not have had my
rings on like that was a really bad move
these zippers are actually Frozen
I have ice crystals that have formed all
over my body frozen fingertips if I
wasn't wearing this I would be
absolutely Frozen I would be a frozen
fish sick and I would be putting myself
into the microwave and having myself for
dinner good luck Jenna good luck it's my
time to go in I don't know how long you
were in there I don't know how long I'm
gonna be in here but my legs are already
cold so scary in here just
here we go
my legs are already cold and it's not
active
three two one
oh it's cold it's very cold
we'll do this without clothes on
I know these pants nope my butt is cold
my legs are very cold my hands are
really cold and my arms are starting to
get very cold okay so my pants are so
cold but when I move it makes it even
worse
people do this for fun I hate losing but
I'm not gonna make it very long like
shiver I'm shivering
people do this without clothes for three
minutes
I'm even though I might not have the
best winter gear on I have on winter
gear
your kit I'm only negative if you get
one not one 55 just 55.
I don't like how I feel my arms are
really cold I'm literally shivering like
I actually think my hands are frozen my
butt is cold my back is cold
Frozen mozzarella stick I I want to get
out my hands are cold I'm tapping out
let me out get out bye
there's ice oh covered in ice there's
frost on me
now I know where the word cry is in it
how did it go Jenna my hands are very
very cold can you feel that yes wow my
arm I wish I had crystals I felt way
more cold though I had like ice crystals
all over my body oh you must have been
in there way longer at the same time
they're kind of three say the amount of
time that you were in there okay okay
two one three minutes 30 seconds eight
minutes dude like I could have went
longer but I was so worried about you
because the only thing that was cold on
me was like my hands started getting a
little chilly my hands were my legs were
so cold that whenever I like moved the
skin would touch the pant then it would
I would feel the coldness again like I
felt nothing on my body my butt probably
nothing like my butt wasn't covered by
the jacket so my butt was cold like my
arms started to get rid like this wasn't
as bad but like I was still like I was I
was shivering like I was actually like
my arms were starting to go like numb
okay that's when they say you got to get
out I did I was like
um so yeah I was not that warm I was so
warm honestly I probably could have
stayed in there for another like 30
minutes around the pond yeah I know but
three minutes without clothes I believe
should I try it without clothes
[Music]
oh my God okay I'm going to do this for
real I'm gonna take my necklace off I
took my rings off this time I'm cold
already I haven't even entered
okay Start Me Up
I'm so cold it hasn't even started yet
okay she's gotta take warm thoughts I
hate it so much oh Jenna oh what oh okay
just if I start getting dizzy I should
get out right I don't know I'm not sure
yet I don't know if I should get out I
feel a little dizzy I'm gonna get out I
feel dizzy okay I feel dizzy feel dizzy
how long did I make it um I don't
actually know it says you have 105
seconds left I got my phone I got a
little dizzy
foreign
I didn't like it well there she goes
okay she's going in okay okay close it
up okay
okay there she goes there she goes she's
so sad look at her look at her then
it's like when you walk in the grocery
store next to the freezer section and
you're like oh that's cold I wasn't
dressed for the grocery store but like
you take off most of your clothes and
walk by it and then get in it I don't
really like it I think I can make 10
more seconds okay I don't can I get out
okay let me get out I'm cold can you
push pause I think you have to pause yes
pause when you come out I don't like it
like little bones feel cold okay so that
was actually so much fun and I really
want to work my way up to being able to
do that for three minutes for real one
day I think it would be good for
everybody considering how cold you
always are maybe you would like build
your tolerance maybe but now it's your
new gear you also you know you don't
really need to build your tolerance you
can just throw on a jacket what about
with your new gear here you go Jenna so
this is a gift for you since you were
the loser of the challenge and you froze
your little buns off yeah in there
Columbia and I wanted to gift you this
wonderful omniheat technology gear we've
got a jacket we've got a shirt and we've
also got some pants for you it's really
tied securely but we
can I know this is nice it's so great we
can match this is very nice are these
pants uh yes but this is the Peyton past
jacket blue is my favorite color I know
that's why I put that one unzip okay and
check this out it's all lined with this
gold this is the Omni heat Infinity
technology oh it's cool yes I know put
that on oh this is like a dream I know
and it's finally getting chilly in La so
it's like jacket weather
oh man although well yeah no I'm ready
to go like the oh they have pockets I
know
so great well thank you so much Jenna
and huge thank you to Columbia for
partnering with us on this video this
was so much fun and I really really do
want to try this again and work my way
up to be able to do a few minutes that's
my my challenge to myself I'm just gonna
stay uh cozy in my jacket and maybe work
my way up thank you guys so much for
watching I'll put a link in the
description if you want to check out the
gear that I was wearing while I did the
cold Zone Challenge and yeah that's it
I'm gonna check it out we are so ready
for the East Coast winter now I know
well even L.A we're gonna do the
mountains Big Bear Big Bear yeah it's
chilly here yeah okay thank you
[Music]
foreign